diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
berker monday
wer cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
schäfer
seit 15 jahren ist heinz gehring im land
unterwegs in schwieriger mission sein
bestreben arbeitslose flüchtlinge in die
hiesige arbeitswelt ja in die schweizer
gesellschaft zu führen
oft scheinen die kulturellen differenzen
unüberbrückbar
doch der mann ist hartnäckig gehrig ein
pionier in der integration fremder
menschen fordert viel doch ebenso
fördert er auch
[Musik]
und wenn wir jetzt muss macht werde ich
dass irgendeine hammer
die probleme die wartet wachsen wenn wir
aber die menschen sowie countrymusik und
unserer wirtschaft zehn monaten vom 8
audi profitiert im jahr 2015 ist heinz
gehrig im luzernischen emmenbrücke tätig
schonungslos begrüßt gehrig die 15
teilnehmer zu dieser gastronom
ausbildung zu diesem integrationskurs
für flüchtlinge priorität die vertraut
und brutal und die muss ich die energie
bringen und das nützt da einfach mit ja
wenn ich ihnen sage versuche denn er
wollte das konnte so irgendwie scope
nicht sondern du hast keine antriebe
auch du musst nagelfeile schön fallen
die damen sowieso ja das ist gut dass
schon viel viel viel besser da noch ein
bisschen daran arbeiten überall da ich
kurz zu agieren und es ist der
fünfwöchige service kurs eine wahre
herausforderung für die flüchtlinge
nicht nur was das richtige platzieren
der flieger anbelangt einmal habe in
beeskow kurs essen mitgebracht weil und
ich habe mit hand gelesen und das war
nicht weise kultur und frau wird man hat
mir gesagt bitte was ist nicht
afghanistan
du musst immer mächtig und eine
servierte bringen
ein teller und danach kannst du gut
essen
das könnte für sie ein problem sein
in diesem kurs haben
es wird punkte die pünktlichkeit
aber ich bin sicher sie werden sich
daran gewöhnen
oh mein gott
die pünktlichkeit in der schweiz ist
eine fundamentale sache ich musste mich
also ändern
so wurde ich von einem der zu spiel
kommt zu einem der rechtzeitig kommt und
ich bin froh darüber so meins
telefontechnik telefon mit dieser kultur
nicht vertraut dass man das richtige zur
richtigen zeit machen muss dass man
pünktlich sein muss dass man keine
lektion verpassen darf dass man im
küchen praktikum nicht fehlen darf
[Musik]
emmenbrücke bei luzern februar 2015
behauptung herr für seat sv ried tesfai
gut dann lassen wir los einen fröhlichen
morgens ossowski heinz gehrig ist ein
freund klarer worte und mit solchen
begrüßte die interessenten für einen
einjährigen integrationskurs wie es
korrekt lisa und soll arbeitslosen
flüchtlingen endlich den beruflichen
einstieg ermöglichen
in der schweiz sind 60 prozent der
flüchtlinge ohne arbeit leben von der
sozialhilfe und das oft jahrelang 1
gehrigs einblick ins kurzprogramm klingt
nicht eben verlockend eher abschreckend
sie werden sehr viele schweißtropfen
haben sie werden manchmal fluchen sie
werden manchmal böse sei mit mir das
weiß ich jetzt schon aber das ziel
das ist klar abschluss mit diesem kurs
das bringt sie weiter werde neumann ich
habe hier typische schweizer normen also
zb die pünktlichkeit in der schweiz
das ist eine norm da steht nirgends
geschrieben aber jeder weiß es die
schweizer werden böse wenn die menschen
zu spät kommen und genau hier lernen sie
solche sachen
jedes mal wenn sie etwas erleben und sie
merken dass der schweizer börse wird
dann ist irgendwo hier etwas falsch
gegangen oder sie wissen es nicht
ich kann ihnen 100 prozent garantieren
diejenigen die den kurs hier beginnen
werden die werden nach einem jahr eine
komplett andere person seien 100 prozent
nun wird selektioniert denn es soll nur
die besten einen platz erhalten
mike kohn der co-leiter verteilt einen
deutschtest
sie möchten die berge nach zermatt
fahren können sie 10 markt senat ist ein
ort wie emmenbrücke luzern
der markt ist ein ort jetzt müssen sie
eine kurze e-mail schreiben dort an die
touristeninformation in diesem e mail
müssen sie fragen wie viel die hotels
kosten instanz ein hotelzimmer in
zermatt wie unwirklich schön muss das
klingen für jene die auf ihrer langen
reise in einem boot auf dem mittelmeer
oder in den straßen italiens mächtige
mussten
disco ist ein pionier kurs für
flüchtlinge angeboten von der
branchenorganisation hotel & gastro
formation wie lange sind sie jetzt schon
in der schweiz seit drei jahren
warum soll ich sehne mich wieso sind sie
besser meine erfahrung aus norden
arbeiten das heißt sie sind motiviert
wie lange sind sie jetzt bereits hinter
schweiz wie lange sind sie hier
ich weiß ja 33 jahre ja wir haben sie
schon einmal in ihrem leben in der
gastronomie gearbeitet noch nie noch nie
der kurs gelegentlich auf lüftungs lehre
genannt findet in der kantine der
einstigen textilfabrik viskose in
emmenbrücke statt
dieses ist nur wenn etwas dafür
erste schritte in einer schweizer küche
schritte welche diese flüchtlinge in die
selbstständigkeit führen sollen
denn bislang waren diese menschen bei
der arbeitssuche erfolg frauen die
erlebt wo das trio covert hand nicht zu
ihrem haus kommen einfach nie in ein
unteres stieg der persönliche so groß
dass einfach der ball eckig und und sie
merkte ich nur alles für andere und wie
sie eigene verdauten die einzige chance
und ich könnte jetzt vom sozialamt
überhaupt die martina zwei stunden
ausbildung
das ist die einzige chance und noch
immer versuchen 1 gierig und mike kohn
herauszufinden wer am besten in den kurs
passt warum ich weiß warum nicht
deutschland oder italien aber warum sind
sie in die chance um chance ist
kommt eine bekannte plan für die
menschenrechte
aber wieso soll ich nehmen sie müssen
besser sein als er sonst nämlich hin und
weil es gerade gut gesundheit und habe
aktiv und ich habe wirklich und ich
immer guten teil ethik die arbeit
gekommen
tsering vom tibetischen flüchtlinge 2015
mit der schweizer arbeitswelt in kontakt
gekommen
vier jahre später das
paraplegiker-zentrum nottwil am
sempachersee 1000 mahlzeiten werden hier
täglich verlangt und all das gebrauchte
geschirr com zu tsering la longue 2015
hat er erfolgreich den res kokos beendet
und seither arbeitet er der einstige
tibetische bauer in der geschirr
einigung des paraplegiker-zentrums ich
habe hier eine stelle gefunden um
mitarbeit alles gut wie hier dann auch
hier möglich kommen ist der staat gut
aber das brauche für weiter für meine
zukunft brauchen mehr andere lernen was
möchtest du lernen wir brauchen etwas
relativ gleich thronicke elektronik ja
ja warum elektronik ich habe gerne
diensten stimmt dann ist sein chef ein
zufriedener chef kann sein und ein
verständnis von jung wo steht ist bis 46
kg waschmaschine steht wenn er sich
wirklich mir geht würde ich liebend
gerne helfen ein anderer stelle oder zum
anderen muss völlig man merkt das organ
oder bis an das macht des ausschusses
ist es zeit dass ich selbst erst 100
also jedes schweizer von der haltinger
zusammen
das machen wofür ich proben ist oder
aber das war ganz sicher dass es ja sehr
eng und lebt alleine in der schweiz seit
sieben jahren seine frau und das
gemeinsame baby musste er in tibet
zurücklassen
die beiden sind der antrieb dafür dass
er zuverlässig jeden tag seine arbeit
leistet an der geschäftsführer
denn er der bislang nur einen f ausweis
hat jenen für vorläufig aufgenommene
möchte sich bewähren so dass er den
ausweis bekommt dann könnte er frau und
kind nach kommen lassen
sein größter wunsch ist so weit weniger
wohl alleine dann manchmal zu hause
alleine dann ist manchmal sofort denker
die über der vater der kinder
da ist ja sehr schwieriger vinzenz
studer sein schweizer chef führt hier
eine sehr internationale küchenbrigade
erholung profitiert und ich glaube
medien sie oder du bist du musst mache
mir wäre nützlich das problem also die
leute sind da und müsse mit denen mit
denen irgend hier braucht ihr konzept
findet man mit denen apple also ich nun
mal so dass manch einer wird der
schweizer für das land ziehen und mit
und fahnenschwingen die titel sind
verbieten
[Musik]
es ist aschermittwoch morgen viele
einheimische schlafen zu dieser zeit die
fasnacht aus über 40 flüchtlinge hatten
sich für einen platz in diesem kurs
beworben
15 haben es geschafft für diese beginnt
heute die verwandlung in eine
arbeitsmarkt fähige person kursleiter
heinz jährige erklärt und zimperlich was
das ziel dieses kurses ist
sie müssen zehn mal besser sein aus all
diese schweizer die hier sind und keine
stelle haben
sie müssen zu beginn steht das fach
werte und normen auf dem stundenplan
womöglich das schwierigste schulfach für
diese menschen aus einer anderen welt
doch zuerst führt kursleiterin doris bot
man die klasse durch die schule
räumlichkeiten und schon bald läuft in
der lingerie eine kleine wertedebatte
gesehen gut ausschaut sie es ist keine
frauenarbeit bügeln können alle das
heißt wenn ich morgen und übermorgen
zeit habe werde ich nur männer
trainieren im winter eine frau ja ich
bin auch nicht gut
die ersten lektionen befassen sich mit
den grundlegenden dingen des lebens
dinge über die man nicht so leicht
spricht
weil es uns machen und bitte stehen sie
nicht auf die toilette
als er die toilette ist nichts um drauf
stehen sondern zum draufsitzen und wenn
sie jetzt lächeln
ich habe das schon gesehen und darum ist
es auch wirklich ganz ganz wichtig mit
diesen taschen etc
die sind da zum duschen und nicht für
pippi woche christen muslime buddhisten
sind hier versammelt doch das soll keine
rolle spielen
religion grundsätzlich müssen sie sich
gut merken es ist absolut unwichtig
welche religion sie haben das ist
absolut unwichtig wichtig ist dass sie
eine haben haben sie die die sie haben
und dass ich die richtige weil welche
die richtige ist das weiß ich auch nicht
heinz gehrig gelernter koch und
erwachsenenbildner ein erfahrener
handwerker der integration
[Musik]
vier jahre sind seit jenem risko kurs
vergangen
heinz gehrig bietet neue flüchtlings
kurse an
seine größte herausforderung flüchtlinge
als pflegehelfer nde auszubilden
er hat ganz große schwierigkeiten
ich brauche ich am anfang während die
kaum zu bekommen müssen umstellen und
die förderrichtlinien und es ist also
dass die die verträge sehr viele
fremdwörter wie der rock legende sind
auto nicht sofort geliefert also sich
ganz am schwierigsten gestaltet mit
15.000 reise ins wallis nach break wo
der pilot kurz zeigen soll ob es
schließlich doch noch klappt eigentlich
war vorstellung
wenn sie bilder im kopf haben die nicht
existieren und sie daran haben wenn sie
ihm und gedanken haben die wie
schrecklich sind die die ihnen angst
machen das nennt man wahnvorstellungen
der einjährige pflegekurs wird in
zusammenarbeit mit dem roten kreuz
oberwallis durchgeführt zuständig ist
nathalie zur welt
sie hat erstaunliches brauchen jetzt
leder und michael schlieben hat es sehr
genossen für die stunde einer rücken op
61 jährig tröstet eine junge tibetische
frau deren mutter liegt in der heimat
dem sterben und ihre tochter kann nicht
bei ihr seien noch stärker als sie im
gastrobereich können in der pflege
kulturelle unterschiede zum stolperstein
werden
diesbezüglich muss dieser kurs einiges
leisten dass es überhaupt ob das heim
gibt mehr an thor nationen zum beispiel
die tibeter gekrönt nicht nachvollziehen
dass autos angeht
das ist für sie also die chance das gibt
es in ganz tibet nehmen und so möchten
wir dass das hätte ein riesen-schritt
von ihnen verlangt das sind auch keine
wie den bereich überhaupt schaffte es
eigentlich gar keine ihre mentalität und
gaga serie ihre satzung verspricht der
tod und seine rituale ein heikles thema
das in einen pflegekurs zur sprache
kommen ist die gewitter die und ihr
verstanden
stückler und verbarg lag und die
wirklich damit die revanche und ich sehe
uns schlag sie jetzt ein moslem zweier
stunden
die männlichen kurs teilnehmer erhalten
heute ideen vermittelt für die
beschäftigung von betanken
es sind nur noch wenige tage bis zum
kurs ende
von den 15 welche die ausbildung
begonnen haben sind noch neun dabei die
anderen mussten vor allem aus
sprachlichen gründen aufgeben und doch
für natalie zur werra ist der pilot kurs
ein erfolg denn die rückmeldungen der
praktikumsbetriebe sind ermutigend wie
der name schon mit ferrostaal egal wo
wirklich sehr wertvoll für die teams sie
also für mich ganz klar es hat sich
gelohnt und die energie das st
das pilotprogramm gewitter bestimmen
einige wochen später das pflegezentrum
englisch groß in brig mittlerweile haben
wegen der neuen kursabsolventen eine
feste anstellung gefunden
drei von ihnen arbeiten hier
so auch jahre osmann ein 35 jähriger
kurde ein schweizweit anerkanntes
pflegehelfer zertifikat des roten
kreuzes befähigt den flüchtling aus dem
irak zu dieser arbeit auch schweizer
können dieses zertifikat erwerben
mit den gleichen prüfungen doch deren
interesse ist eher gering
deshalb sind diese flüchtlinge für
schweizer keine konkurrenz im gegenteil
es herrscht ein pflegenotstand über
10.000 stellen in der pflege sind nicht
besetzt
[Musik]
nein
ist reinlegen
[Musik]
die einzige frage und ich mir eigentlich
schneller ist weil ich mich vor der
person noch fliegen und dann ist die mit
ja beantworten sie sagen spielt für mich
läuft das land unter anderen ein zürcher
und dann stimmt es für mich und die hand
und erzeugung zu der mannschaft ist das
nicht nennen wollte daran hatten wir nun
alle von messtechnik
ich hab gesagt von allen die da
reinkommen sollte nur alles ein ge und
dann über schon gut gelöst werden ja
bitte dass ich wahrheit
für solche leute haben wir immer 100
prozentig ehrlich redlich
ungerechtfertigten da wirklich auch die
augenbewegungen mohammed hat dank dem
pflegekurs hier eine arbeit gefunden
dabei sah es anfänglich eher düster aus
denn die deutsche sprache und dann noch
der walliser dialekt
das war der 22 jährigen frau aus somalia
einfach zu fremd und damit zeit grund so
verstehe jetzt viel besser als vorher
vor 301 der gar nicht weiß wie schön
viel
aber alles kaum geld und ich bin froh
mit wir in der schweiz komme und
pflegeheim macher selbst verdient habe
selbst freundliche mitarbeiterin und die
waren
[Musik]
am urnersee bei früheren fast in
sichtweite zum rütli so wie man sagt die
schweiz ihren anfang nahm
[Applaus]
einmal im monat spielt heinz gehrig beim
schloss rudens mit einigen freunden
better nicht alle stammbäume dieser
männer reichen bis zum rütli zurück
einige vorfahren kamen als italienische
gastarbeiter zum tunnel und autobahnbau
ins land am gotthard geblieben sind die
italienischen namen doch der rest ist
längst ohne risch geworden
klar die einwanderung die neuen fremden
es sind auch hier ein brennendes thema
heinz gehrig der auf allen kontinenten
als koch unterwegs war berichtet über
ein schlüsselerlebnis für mich war er
vom baum hinauf und ich weiß eigentlich
normaler unfall und da weiß ich nicht
mehr
und da haben mir steht das von der hutu
familie im bus so haben nach der wieder
zusammengeflickt und xi b aber die
kleine maddie gesorgt berichtet dass
oder warum dahingehend einfach komplett
und das in so ein spiel wo schinkel
nicht dazu bewogen haben vertraut sich
lied setzen können dann aber umso besser
sagte dielitz
die muss mal wieder reichlich 50 express
die für den snack aus freundschaftlich
musste für die jene dass so viele fremde
menschen in die schweiz kommen
beschäftigt die ohne männer 1 gehrig
erzählt von seiner arbeit
wieso schweiz visionen einer und frauen
krieg dänemark und schweiz und der helm
iranischen teilnahme zu erhalten war
biggs im internet und zwar die die
werbekunden ein hauptgrund mit dem court
zu futtern und der kunde der große
trumpf mit dem peter li und da hat er
sich sein gerade wenn dir so gut zu der
die ruhe wird stellte vor wie die zu der
mönche und das ist durchaus und vergesse
ich nie natürlich
manche rufen und integriert nicht und
attraktivität von einst wird wichtige
muschel integrieren so stolz gar nichts
das muss ob es das passt oder nicht man
müsse versuchen integrierten man muss
den job kann ob es eine vernünftige
jetzt grundsatz problemen
[Musik]
und sie
erneut versucht heinz gehrig bei seinen
schülern der sinn für werte und normen
zu schärfen zu zeigen das was hier gilt
andernorts unverständlich ist und
umgekehrt
auf allzu große feinheiten kann er bei
seiner weltreise allerdings keine
rücksicht nehmen wenn sie durch die welt
reisen dann können sie ganz böse
überraschungen erleben heinz gehrig malt
mit dem breiten pinsel in china ist es
absolut normal dass man überhaupt auf
den boden spuckt wenn sie in brasilien
sind dann dürfen sie nie persönliche
fragen stellen
alles was persönlich ist ein tabu und
das ist typisch deutschland nur deutsche
kommen auf die idee irgendwo auf dieser
welt in die ferien zu gehen und einfach
nackt in den sand zu setzen und da bin
ich kein anderes land führte das machen
aber deutschland macht das und darum
denken sie wie thema daran werte und
normen das ist nicht richtig oder falsch
in diesem land ist es so und in dem land
ist es so und am besten fahren sie
einfach wenn sie in dem land wo sie sind
das annehmen wo in diesem land noch mal
ich
[Musik]
von den wänden lächeln den flüchtlingen
die beruflichen vorbilder entgegen
schöne glückliche menschen zieht bald so
auch das eigene leben aus weil es geht
nichts schlimmeres als wenn sie auf der
toilette setzen damit die kleine weiße
papier ist im gleichen raum passiert und
stellte sich vor das passiert uns einen
gast
das ist peinlich wird der code nie mehr
wir machen mit ihrer tollen reise kann
es ein bisschen einbauten dann machen
wir so ein spitz ganz einfach und nun
ein leben in den grund sagen
noch im sommer schluss einen spitz macht
über das ist also begrüßung nur wenn
also schon die erste geburt und genau
wenn sie so ein eingeschaltetes wette
papierseiten wissen sie automatisch vom
kopf hat diese toilette geeinigt haben
sonst keine frage dass nur die ganze
übung das war eine
da niemand wirklich es gibt auch noch
eine gebrannte für einen zwischen
reinigung eine grundreinigung und dann
könnte es noch eine saison einigung
[Musik]
das leben in der schweiz begann für
tascis am 2013 im asyl empfangszentrum
kreuzlingen
der täter war 17 jahre alt ein junger
mann ohne jegliche schulbildung
doch offenbar intelligent und mit einem
starken willen es hier zu schaffen
er verstand kein wort deutsch musste das
lesenlernen unterschreiben
haben sie überhaupt gewusst dass es die
schweiz gibt
ich weiß nicht
bekannt sind sie zwei jahre jährigen der
schweiz
was haben sich die träume für die
zukunft
zum einen zukommt also ja so kommt er
also ich arbeite und ja wenn ich also
gut so werde dann also ich hoffe meine
älteren hinterher springen kanada
tschechien
geflogen als jugendlicher vor der
chinesischen unterdrückung in seiner
heimat angekommen
nach einer langen gefährlichen reise in
luzerner hinterland
ich habe ja so seid ja vier jahre mehr
als meine mit meiner älteren kunden
gehabt und nicht gehört
in altishofen bewohnt tasche mit zwei
landsleuten eine gemeinsame wohnung
das rezept für die tibetischen
teigtaschen stammt von seiner mutter mit
der nicht in kontakt treten darf weil er
sie sonst gefährden würde
wenn tasche nach hause schreiben könnte
wie würde er seinen eltern die schweiz
schildern die die menschen sind sehr
nett und hier ist sehr gut auch
interessieren oder so
das ist sehr gut und und
hier ist also demokratisch ist sehr gut
reagiert für duft künstler durchgesetzt
heute schauen wir seit einigen monaten
trainiert tasche bei den a junioren vom
team weh getan
hier spricht man schweizerdeutsch ich
hab mich ist ein bisschen schwierig aber
das ist sehr interessant weil das ich
habe ja so interessant und ich hoffe
dass sie auch fussball hat sie erst in
der schweiz kennengelernt
fußball die große integrations maschine
[Musik]
etwas außerhalb von luzern
das seehotel ermitage letzter tag des
küchen praktikums von tascis am der
anfang war hart todmüde war der junge
tibeter jeweils abends bleischwer die
knochen
er hat durchgestanden der küchenchef ist
sehr zufrieden begeistert von dem sie
sagen was mir gefällt ist dass es sind
sie aufnahmefähig das macht derzeit voll
machen und dann setzte sie dass der
spieler die schon gleich tun haben sie
wirklich toll gemacht sind immer mit
elan dran geblieben und vor allem was
mir sehr gefällt mir auch immer mit
einem rechen
ich bin erst mal dass ich also in kings
arbeiten und ich habe es so viele von
hier erfahrung und so viele dass das bin
ich sehr zufrieden tasche touch an hat
den rekurs einige tage vor dem ende
verlassen
und dieser abgang des 19 jährigen ist
eine erfolgsmeldung tasche hat selber
eine stelle gesucht und diese im
luzerner restaurant tibits bekommen wer
eine anstellung findet darf denn risko
kurs jederzeit verlassen
aus dem einstigen tibetischen bauern
jungen ist ein adretter kellner geworden
ja also das sind ein bisschen also ein
schönes gefühl für mich und
und so ein bisschen mit dem gast zu
reden
da habe ich ein bisschen schiss
zugebunden tasche hat sein ziel erreicht
doch es bleibt der sehnlichste wunsch
dass er bald in kontakt treten kann mit
seinen eltern die in der tibetischen
heimat unter chinesischer besatzung
leben seit vier jahren hat der
19-jährige nichts mehr von ihnen gehört
heute lebt tashi zang in einem ruhigen
aussenquartier von luzern
die bauprofile zeigen dass es nur eine
vorübergehende bleibe ist es ist ein
arbeitsfreier tag und tasche hat einen
tibetischen kollegen zum brunch
eingeladen
[Musik]
in den vergangenen vier jahren hat sich
wichtiges verändert für den tibetischen
flüchtlinge verändert zum guten
seine eltern konnten aus tibet fiel
mitsamt den kindern heute leben sie als
flüchtlinge in indien tasche konnte zu
ihnen reisen nach so vielen jahren der
schmerzvollen ungewissheit konnte er
seine mutter wieder sehen
sie hat mir fast nicht gekannt weil ich
so groß geworden bin und dann ja uns für
mich war auch so
für mein gefühl ist beides so und
traurig und glücklich beide weil sie hat
mir das nicht gekannt und ich habe ich
glaube ihr gekannt und dann und ich habe
gesehen mein motor ist hier und ich bin
zu ihr gegangen und sie hat mir gesagt
sie war ein bisschen nervös sie konnten
aber sie hat das gewusst dass sie komme
uns war es sich also so gut im moment
also gewesen
[Musik]
meine jüngste bruder ist auch mit ihr
gekommen und ich bin also würdest du ihm
eine tortur geblieben
und dann
und das ist dann mein vater aber auch in
indien ist die tibetische exil gemeinde
bedroht der indische präsident empfängt
seinen chinesischen amtskollegen und er
unternimmt alles um den mächtigen
nachbarn nicht so erzogen
so werden die bäder vorsorglich ins
gefängnis gesteckt
[Musik]
aber moment habe meinen unter anderem
india und der nenne ich eigentlich in
dem moment als gut
aber ja also eben das ist für vor allem
wir sind in einer familie und müssen an
tibeter das heißt wenn ein teenager
nicht so gut geht dann ist der ausgleich
so daher es ist wirklich traurig
in einer luzerner landgemeinde hellen
meyer und ihr mann haben sich mit tasche
angefreundet
das schicksal des jungen flüchtlings hat
sie berührt
heute hilft hellen meyer dem tibeter
beim gesuch für eine
aufenthaltsbewilligung eine sogenannte b
bewilligung die bürokratischen hürden
sind sehr hoch
über die letzten fünf jahre das müsstest
du auch selbst persönlich hinzu du hast
verdienen
honig und auch bestätigung von dem
arbeitgeber das ziemlich sondern
unbefristet ist also dass du wieder
hoffe dass das nicht nur zeit bis ende
oktober so denn mit lohnabhängigen
easycash für die marke cab und zwar über
die letzten zwölf minuten konto auf eine
ganze jahr musst du die ganze bank von
dem postkonto ausdruck wie hängt das
source laut theorie leicht hat es
frühestens nach vier vier reichen
das haben wir gemacht und mir händ
leider die negative entscheidung
begründe körper wer mit einer negativen
entscheid geholt und auch telefonisch
erfragt und mir eigentlich keine geben
antworte ich hoffe ich natürlich dass
mit dem geld aus der tasche die b
bewilligung bekommt es hat sich sehr
engagiert wir schaffen ein
arbeitszeugnis büro könnte mich immer
mehr integriert und so hoffen wir dass
es da mal klappt warum dieses große
bemühen um eine bewilligung
wenn ich eine bewilligung bekommt dann
hat er ja chance dass ich in meinem
leben erreichen können zum beispiel wenn
ich jetzt momentan eigentlich die elf
bewegung mit dem ist schwierig zb
legalen letzten machen möchte und so
weiter das so es ist wirklich so schön
also ich seh schon vielleicht noch das
heißt sie schnitt sich an sagt noch ab
liebe mit der bewilligung ist das sicher
das auto blieb das hilft ihm auch in der
evonik sucht das dezimierte
genossenschaft nehmen am mittwoch in den
b bewilligung hat und das sind ja vor
allem auf die günstige wohnungen
es geht auch ohne bewilligung wind für
einen stellen will sich sie dass die
lieder beliebig und so kämpft man sich
weiter durch den fragekatalog der
migrationsbehörde keine einfache sache
in der schweiz anzukommen
warum leistet hellen meyer diese
unterstützung sind flüchtling die hand
mir sehr aktiv und jetzt laut cbs
und da finde ich es einfach wichtig dass
mit die luft unterstützte integration
und es braucht auch telefonie schweizer
dass wir auf die leads erkennt dass mir
den haag findet sich nur integrieren wir
auch mit
fußball im verein genau diese
bestätigung hat das dritte leben und
dass du damit machst ja das ist gott was
man da hören und dass man auf okinawa
[Musik]
frühmorgendliche fahrt durch die
zentralschweiz ein kleinbus voller
junger männer unter ihnen auch tascis an
mittlerweile spieler beim fc bate
pilatus am steuer der einzige nicht
tibeter michael owen hunt der
holländische fußball trainer am
hintereingang von luzern steuert der bus
einen zwischenstopp an
hier werden weitere passagiere
aufgeladen
in einer schäbigen hüttensiedlung leben
einige dutzend abgewiesener asylbewerber
darunter auch spieler der tibetischen
mannschaft
[Musik]
diego
heute ist das ganz klare ziel polen
einfach alles daran setzen um die
kürzung sowie im letzten training haben
wir am anfang nicht so gut gespielt aber
noch alles ist super gegangen
junge tibeter alle mit einer ähnlichen
biografie doch mit unterschiedlichen
asyl entscheiden
einige glückliche wie tasche können fuß
fasst nun in der schweiz
andere hier haben ein ablehnendes urteil
erhalten sind zu illegalen erklärt
worden
doch heute gilt nur das paar glück
vielleicht reicht es sogar zu gold 22
tibetische mannschaften aus der ganzen
schweiz kämpfen darum sie heißen fc
himalaya zürich/basel boys oder eben fc
tibet pilatus aus seinen namen die
verraten dass dieser junge menschen ihre
heimat nicht vergessen haben eine heimat
die sie wohl nie mehr zurückkehren
können
[Musik]
willst du lieber ankommende maschinen
sind und du willst du leben heute
missbrauchen konnte mir dass die taschen
hat sich beruflich verbessert im
restaurant tibits im luzerner bahnhof wo
er seit vier jahren seit dem release
kokos arbeitet hilft er nun bei der
einführung von neulingen womöglich sie
die große haben die kleine aber feine
creek sub das werdet dann große und
kleine 47 rappen mal gegen feng shui
fließen
[Musik]
aber
heute verdient sich der tibetische
flüchtlinge seinen lebensunterhalt
selbst und es bleibt auch noch etwas
geld das er seinen eltern nach indien
schicken kann der bauernbub ohne
schulbildung hat sich viel erkämpft so
bald wie möglich möchte er eine lehre
machen und da sind noch größere pläne
haben soll und damit der sich das wasser
ständig so habe ich eine planung in
meine also zu kunden ist schön aber neue
jahr zusammen danke
rusche loidolt leiteten wie esco service
kurs seit seinem dritten lebensjahr sei
er der gastronomie verfallen sagt er
servieren das sei der biss der beruf der
welt und das will er seinen schülern mit
allen mitteln verdeutlichen
jetzt komme ich zum gast und frage sind
sie bedient darf ich aber räumen sind
sie bedient darf ich abholen jetzt nehme
ich diesen teller wieder mit der rechten
hand nicht mit der linken oder nicht mit
der linken wieder mit der rechten hand
auf und übergebe ihnen wieder der linken
habe als ich ein reines ping und paul
hin und her
für die menschen aus afrika und asien
bedeutet all das eine neue haben nur ein
thema von alles für salat von asien
aber hier in mainz mit haben
verschiedene themen verschiedene gläser
verschiedene messer und wir laufen nicht
mit einer anderen in den sechsten stock
der erster stock
[Musik]
es ist die zweite woche im service kurs
und der iosco leiter müssen
notfallmässig anreisen
die klasse ist verzweifelt die
flüchtlinge fühlen sich überfordert
zu viele fachausdrücke davon die meisten
in unverständlichem französisch zwei
wochen in st
und dann ist ihnen die brauchen wir
nicht verstehen abend genau lesen
was leser nicht mit glenn gould klären
sie haben es in einem jahr was haben sie
alles gelernt werte und normen stärken
schwächen
sie haben gelernt mit teile
hauswirtschaft küche
überall hat es fachwörter jetzt kommen
neue fachwörter dazu sie dürfen nicht
denken dass jetzt alles sofort sich
merken können wir wollen nicht dass sie
uns zehn weichs weiter aufzählen können
wenn sie mir zwei sagen können bin ich
happy
mehr brauche ich nicht sie müssen mir
auch nicht sämtliche trauben erklären
können auch das brauchen wir nicht
aber sie müssen wissen dass es einen
weißen war ein gibt einen roten und
einen rosé heinz gehrig ist gefordert
er musste verunsicherte klasse wieder
ins boot holen
ich habe jetzt eine lösung immer wenn
sie die situation haben dass sie etwas
nicht verstehen
machen sie so und dann weiß halt halt
stopp und dann wird er von uns anfragen
was verstehen sie nicht
perica these feiern besonders
pflichtbewusster schüler hatte den
service unterricht sogar weinen
verlassen
also nicht davonlaufen weil wenn sie das
es würde niemand verstehen
am abend gab es eis meine ganze rotation
ich spüre dass sie ein bisschen zeit
besitzt haben den sie heute nach hause
und morgen kommen sie ganz normal ich
dann könne sie ein bisschen
amerikanesche flüchtlinge aus eritrea
wird nach dem kurs seiner anstellung
finden in einem fünf-sterne-hotel in der
innerschweiz dann in eine woche habe ich
wieder vorbei
so haben wir eine lösung
in der küche des hotels waldstetter hof
in luzern
seit jahren schon können flüchtlinge aus
dem ries kurs hier die realität keine
lernen
es ist die zweite woche des küchen
praktikums für den afghanen isabella at
er hat in diesem hotel bereits das
hauswirtschafts praktikum gemacht
der afghane ist glücklich dass er hier
arbeiten darf
doch da ist immer auch eine tiefe
melancholie die sprache von leuten ich
kann es besser mit häufig aber hier das
verspätet oder durch den man gute
sprache das wäre deswegen ist kommt dort
macht er mit natürlich von mir ein
bisschen deswegen nicht betragen
mein land ist bis jetzt für mich muss ja
schon mal sein dass er mein land ist
immer möglich die tiger hat meine mutter
oder vater bei der geburt
ich meine du erst mal ganz groß gefeiert
werden
grausam ist die lebensgeschichte von
isabella hatte doch seine
liebenswürdigkeit ließ er sich nicht
nehmen die latte der afghane in einer
gänzlich anderen kultur angekommen
am stadtrand von luzern
viel verkehr viele ausländer hier hat
dieser will ja die eine wohnung gefunden
erste sehr laut wir gehen diese sofort
ihr bus fort zu viel
darum so weise die leute wollen nicht
sind solche wunder meisten bei uns ist
dann meistens alles ist verloren
er rettete ja aus somalia aus afrika zum
beispiel aus asien so viele debattieren
afghane runde pakistaner indianer sind
alle hier nicht gesehen weil diese
wohnung diese gebäude hat eine sehr
schöne aussicht und das ich finde sehr
gut für die luft ist jemand war isabella
harte arbeit tätig immer noch in der
gastrobranche ein zufriedener mensch ich
bin stolz auf mich weil ich meiner
selbstständige person
ich fühle es sehr gut vorher ich habe
von sozialhilfe bekommen es war sehr gut
seit fast drei jahren drei jahren ich
bin ein selbstständige person ich bis
alle selber meine krankenkasse alles
selber wohnen mit und ich meine das ist
genug von der natur und tierpark goldau
ich muss meine durch verbessern weil das
ist sehr wichtig wer in zukunft finden
jones die kochlehre ich habe sehr gerne
kuchen arbeiten
und da ist aliya 28 jahre alt saß
verlobte in pakistan die allerdings erst
über das internet kennt stiefmutter card
für mich gesucht gesehen oder so sie
sich denn dieses dort fragen arbeitet
nicht weil es ist verboten
ich habe meine frau immer gesagt wenn du
kommst kannst du ein bisschen leben und
jetzt sagt ja ok und irgendwann soll es
ein fest geben dann will isabella die
nach pakistan reisen um seine schöne
frau zu heiraten
[Musik]
der waldstetter hof beim bahnhof luzern
das schmucke drei sterne hotel ist seit
vier jahren der arbeitsplatz von
isabella at hier wo er bereits das risko
praktikum gemacht hat
zehn leute arbeiten in der küche
menschen aus sieben ländern und dem
ganzen hotel unternehmen sind es noch
einige nationalitäten mehr
der multikulturelle betrieb wird von
susanne grabau und ihren mann geführt
sie werden in schweizer in der bbs coco
der apache ii score der hochofen putzer
wohnzimmer coco reiniger mit findet
freilich ist am montag wurde zudem eine
schweizerin zahlen eigentlich höhere
löhne in gstaad nicht abgestimmt auf
nationalitäten sondern das bild ist man
der gesamtarbeitsvertrag unter dem meer
ist halter egal
und noch bevor der große mittags sturm
in der küche losbricht versuchen sich
das personal in der kantine zum essen
und auch das ist eine kultur frage
schweinefleisch etwa ist der muslim
isabella jati nicht bekannt
und eigentlich verbietet der islam jetzt
im ramadan überhaupt das essen zu dieser
tageszeit
der ramadan das islamische fasten wäre
mit den anforderungen die in der
schweizer küche gestellt werden kaum
vereinbar
und so kommen hier viele geschichten
zusammen schöne aber auch dramatische
von einer art die das schweizer
vorstellungsvermögen übersteigen kann
abbrecher von risco weil dies mehrfach
vergewaltigt wurde in ihrem heimatland
die richtige verfolgungswahn kann
die hat mir keine stoffe zb märz immer
woanders suchen hat und der zweitürer
konzern stützt hat das thema und man
vielfach wirklich unter verfolgungswahn
liegt mancity betreut werden
psychologisch mit größtem es geschafft
mit wissen seiner branche leider im
luzerner grand hotel national beginnt
dem risiko kurs ali haschemi sein
hauswirtschafts praktikum die abläufe
scheinen klar und simpel doch in einem
solch gehobenen haus sind selbst beim
bettenmachen und putzen vieler finessen
zu beachten
[Musik]
ein charmanter junger mann aufgeweckt
und mit guter arbeitsleistung doch mit
den regeln des kurses kommt er nicht
klar
zu oft fehlte unentschuldigt schließlich
verliert er diese praktikumsstelle der
gros der kosten viel geld und es geht
100 die dose wo das auge an würde machen
und darum würde mir nur die richtige
lied in dem kurs so schicht das geld
falsch investiert
das hören wir dass ein fenster werden
genau prüfen und das wetter steht der 19
jährige afghane versiebt auch noch die
letzte chance er muss den release kokos
schließlich verlassen
auf dem sportplatz in willisau wo er
früher fußball spielte ringt er um eine
erklärung dass das ist nicht mitgemacht
haben
ich ersuche ich bedanke mich für das
semester straße gehabt aber ich als so
sektor zum nicht gesehen
ich kann einfach das gemacht was ich im
kopf gehabt schweiz ist die einzige
westerland woche haben wir billiger zu
machen
ali haschemi mittlerweile vater eines
kleinen sohnes arbeitet nach dem release
kurs zeitweise auf dem bau dann ist er
wieder ohne arbeit
[Musik]
in emmenbrücke versammelt sich die
klasse um die vergangenen
praktikumswochen zu besprechen
auch sauber 2 ist aus ihrem praktikum
zurückgekehrt die eritreerin ist mit
einer traumatischen bootsfahrt über das
mittelmeer nach europa gelangt jetzt
hofft sie wie alle hier ihr leben in der
schweiz verbessern zu können
wie hat mir das praktikum gefallen auf
der einen seite oder überhaupt nicht
gefallen und dann warum die meisten
waren sehr zufrieden
viele gar zu 100 prozent kursleiter
heinz gehrig kann es kaum glauben
jetzt wird es mir langsam unheimlich
jede runde wird sein auch zapatero hatte
fünf gute praktikumswochen einzig ein
erlebnis betrieb keine tag so finden
arbeit keine tanz bedingtheit die frau
angenehmen arbeitsplatz
was aber sie haben das super wir sie
haben im prinzip die eine antwort schon
gegeben oder diese frau hat angst gehabt
dass ich seine konkurrentin weil die
haben alle angst dass sie besser sind
und wenn sie besser sind bekommen sie
die stelle weil wir wollen ja nur die
besten im arbeitsmarkt die rückmeldungen
der praktikumsbetriebe klingen
durchzogen die person wirkt sehr
unmotiviert die person ist nicht
belastbar wird schnell müde und immer
etwas tut weh tut weh tut weh dass ich
nur mal was wir dann sehr gut gefallen
hat ist ich habe viele viele
rückmeldungen bekommen dass die
persönliche hygiene
sehr gut war das hat mich wahnsinnig
gefreut
ich weiß von da wo sie herkommen ist die
arbeit komplett anders und jetzt kommen
sie in ein komisches system wie die
schweiz und jetzt müssen sie vom von
irgendwo auf 100% 150 prozent hoch das
ist nicht einfach das braucht zeit aber
man muss es schaffen
die hoffnungen von sabbats werden sich
vorerst nicht erfüllen ihre arbeit nach
dem kurs wird sie krankheitsbedingt
aufgeben müsse
[Musik]
das schuljahr ist fast schon überstanden
da werden die flüchtlinge noch aufs
glatteis geführt
und wenn sie warm und kein problem es
ist wie im richtigen leben stehen sie
wieder auf machen sie weiter
diese männer und frauen haben schon
gewaltmärsche durch den himalaya
denn ihr sehen der taliban und
lebensbedrohliche boots passagen auf dem
mittelmeer überlebt da werden sie auch
noch das luzerner theaters überstehen
irgendwie sie müssen das gewicht nach
vorne lagen
und wenn sie wenn sie einen sturz gibt
besser nach vorne und nach in brasilien
mose ski gott sie journalist und
menschenrechtsaktivist der aus seiner
heimat uganda fliehen musste und nun mit
etwas hilfe in kleinsten schritten
unterwegs auf fremdem terrain
[Musik]
immer wieder aufstehen wie im richtigen
leben
das haben sie alle schon gemacht sonst
wären sie nicht hier
der nachweis dass sorgen so sein
die prüfung ist nicht einfach wir wollen
viel wissen wir wollen mehr wissen als
es manchmal vielleicht nötig ist aber je
mehr als sie wissen umso besser wird
dass ihnen nach ergehen
die schüler sind angespannt in zwei
tagen ist das schuljahr zu ende
heute sind die abschlussprüfungen in den
fächern service und kochen dem
erscheinungsbild rosa socken haben wir
uns noch ganz schnell an
hier der springer hat es so dass dunkle
wird und ob ich das helle weiße bier
unterbrochen quasi oder aufgehellt mit
der fliege dann die fingernägel
sie sehen gut aus na ja da ist ein glas
viel kaffee tätig
genau um dieses gas haben wir dann auch
in der küche im untergeschoss macht sich
die andere hälfte der klasse für die
koch prüfung bereit ein vier-gang-menü
soll es geben
suppe nach bauart dies einer der gänge
des prüfungs menüs
[Musik]
der mann aus uganda mussten küchenchef
spielen
moses gott sie hat schon pläne für die
zeit nach dem sv er möchte an der
luzerner hochschule einen
englischsprachigen tourismus lehrgang
beginnen
das ziel von moses größe von der
sozialhilfe wegkommen die
selbstständigkeit erlangen
vier jahre später das park hotel vitznau
einer der besten adressen am
vierwaldstättersee
jetzt muss alles alleine schaffen muss
alles bis 11 uhr alles bereit
die kantine bereit alles getränke alles
brotsuppe preisen alles vorbereitet
sondern mittlerweile hat moses giegold
sie eine beeindruckende berufliche
karriere gemacht der flüchtlinge aus
afrika leitet das personalrestaurant des
fünf sterne hauses
wie kommt sie gut putzen so
meine gäste willkommen und an alle sind
sauber
[Musik]
also
[Applaus]
alles bereit
es ist 11 was braucht es in der fremden
schweiz zu recht zu kommen man muss
selber das wie kann das dann alles
tiptop zweiter ist disziplin und ein
display in der schweiz man geht das
nicht weiter
[Musik]
und moses keynotes möchte noch
weiterkommen einen tourismus master der
hochschule luzern hat er bereits
erworben
nun will er sich auch in der küche
verbessern
in diesem weiterbildungskurs für hilfs
köche kursleiter michael hofmann nicht
beeindruckt vom wirken des dass es ist
der letzte kurs tag prüfungstag
teilnehmer acht nation schweizer sind
hier in der minderheit
durch das bereitet stephan jungk eine
gutschrift einiges zusammen ob es sich
ein bisschen heißem wasser
die große welt im kleinen die schweizer
küche ein modell für eine friedlich
funktionierende welt prüfungs experte
mark bachmann ist seit 40 jahren in
dieser branche tätig spanien erklärt
jährlich sparen
wir haben cach bleibt oder die hand
nehmen oder ohne oscar gewinners termine
funktionieren es hat sich auch schon
problem gar bankenkrise gewarnt hat eine
bewegte einwanderer geschichte der
türkische vater ein fußball profi beim
fc zürich
die portugiesische mutter einer
schülerin an der bahnhofstraße
aufgewachsen bei schweizer pflegeeltern
auch ein hauch wenn das geht sehr viel
viel energie und selbstlos damit sie das
programm was sie erwartet da überhaupt
moralisch wände schlagen
dazu will
was nächsten tag von schulen dadurch
[Musik]
also meine daumen werden die hießen die
gäste sind da
das geht jetzt los
[Musik]
ja
heinz gehrig reist nach brüssel
das schweizer fernsehen berichtet der
pionier in der integration von
flüchtlingen ist vom schweizer
botschafter eingeladen worden
gehrig soll europäischen fachleuten das
von ihm aufgebaute jesko
integrationsmodell vorstellen wo rossi
wies important du uns ist es wichtig die
richtigen kurs teilnehmer auszuwählen
und dafür gibt es gute gründe
wir wollen von ihnen weder zu viel noch
zu wenig verlangen
wir wollen dass den teilnehmern bewusst
ist auf was sie sich da einlassen bevor
sie sich für den kurs verpflichten
kalli ferien während dieses jahres hat
die arbeit arbeit am wochenende und am
abend
unglücklicherweise muss heute ein
flüchtling fähigkeiten vorweisen die 50
prozent höher liegen als bei einem
schweizer nur schon in zu einem
bewerbungsgespräch eingeladen zu werden
und da hat mich vor allen dingen
beeindruckt dass man sehr starken wert
auf die werte und das essverhalten in
der schweiz also im vest in der
westlichen welt legt ein sehr
interessanter punkt ist dass die
flüchtlinge auf grund ihrer haltung
ausgewählt und darin auch trainiert
werden das ist ein schlüssel zum erfolg
dies war eine sehr interessante
botschaft ich hatte dies zuvor noch nie
so deutlich
menschen die in der schweiz in der
westlichen welt arbeiten müssen die
werte und die verhaltensweisen
kennenlernen und sie auch befolgen
das ist ein absolutes muss und das ist
häufiger nicht so der fall dass man
darauf so großen wert legt wenn sich
mitglieder unserer business community
zur integration von migranten äußern
dann wird exakt dieser punkt
angesprochen ok die sprache ist ein
problem
doch das ist lösbar die beruflichen
fähigkeiten sind ein problem anders ist
es mit der haltung den wirken der
migranten
diese wissen nichts über die
arbeitskultur in den niederlanden und
genau in diesen werten werden die
flüchtlinge in diesem projekt
unterrichtet fachleute etwas ratlos ob
der millionen von asylsuchenden die nach
europa gekommen sind
ein integrationsmodell aus der schweiz
liefert erkenntnisse wie die soziale
eingliederung dieser fremden menschen
besser vonstatten gehen könnte
[Musik]
frühmorgens noch vor dem stau der
pendler erneut ist heinz gehrig
unterwegs im land heute nach effretikon
ein ganztägiger besprechungs marathon
steht auf dem programm
im kurs zentrum des baumeisterverbandes
zürich schaffhausen wird entscheidendes
verhandelt es ist das ende eines
reaktors im baubereich und eine
maurerlehre ist das ziel der
anstrengungen und dann versammeln sich
arbeitgeber ausbilder und flüchtlinge im
halbstundentakt zwei monate hat das
maurer praktikum gedauert
zuvor waren die flüchtlinge von der
ausbildner reto steiner
81 tage ins mauer handwerk eingeführt
worden
wie waren die leistungen vom kauf die
klassen wie waren sie zufrieden
oder städtische bestellt sind im 4
und für sie ist ja ich habe keine
schwierige zum arbeiten oder schwierige
etwas sagen jetzt alle zufrieden
aus einem land aus den boden für ihre
sitzungen besprochen wie ein kollege aus
geschäftsleitung der hier haben mir
würde dem eine praktikums lehrstelle
anbieten
ich habe ja ein paar wunderbare
rückmeldungen bekommen die möchte ich
ihnen jetzt geben er war immer da und
hat nie gefehlt
das persönliche auftreten sehr gut er
ist nett man mag ihn von der
sprachkenntnisse her ist genügend bis
gut man kann sich mit ihnen unterhalten
aber es muss weiter gefördert werden und
welche noten an schauer jahren von der
schule die sind sicher noch ein bisschen
verbesserungsfähig grad der lehrer hat
so verzerrt
das ist um haben wir als sehr engagierte
mitarbeiter kennengelernt
er wurde gut aufgenommen er hat sich
wirklich eingesetzt auch ich habe durchs
band eigentlich einen guten eindruck
gewonnen das ist auch der grund dass wir
jetzt in abklärung sind so für hinaus
lehrlinge auch einstellen können also
sie haben gehört sie sind der markt
klären und sie würden ihnen gerne eine
lehrstelle geben wie ich das für sie
parat gemacht ab und das gefällt mir ja
auch da auch in lehrstelle weitermachen
so kommt immer gepflegt sehr gute
motivation immer pünktlich verhalten im
team sehr gut
genial
danke vielmals kurt tichy später
deutschprüfung 1 gierig erhält einen
telefonanruf von seinem sekretariat ein
kurs absolvent könne nicht zum gespräch
erscheinen probleme mit der polizei
das problem mit der ich vor der kripo
fest carter wurde ja aber sie haben
nichts heute um was das gott wir sagen
nicht nur 2 3 im akw fukushima kann nach
den anti einfach mit wie sie dort auch
knallige handel ist das ipad abos recht
hätte oder nieder und ich freue mich
über gebe ich ihnen das wort das sie uns
vielleicht etwas erzählen können zu den
leistungen wie sie zufrieden sind wieder
mehr um
also wir haben ihn auch sehr fleißigen
und interessierten jungen menschen
können und auch schätzen gelernt und wir
sind eigentlich überzeugt dass er das
handwerkliche geschick hat und auch eine
maurerlehre absolvieren zu können was
wir noch etwas zwei vorhaben ist ob er
schulisch sprich vor allem mit dem
deutsch ob das auch wirklich genug gut
kann ich denke da vor allem an zu lesen
ich kann mich ein guter und raubte mit
ihm somit könnten und müssten versteht
was ich einen von hinwil
aber ich brauche für die schule erreicht
das noch nicht der junge irritiere ist
enttäuscht dass er nicht gleich die
maurerlehre beginnen kann dass er noch
ein jahr warten sich in der deutschen
sprache
verbessern sei kommen drei personen vom
kurs genau das gleiche thema ich habe
mir schon gesagt er muss nicht nur
deutschland man muss auch noch
schweizerdeutsch lernen und italienisch
bei mir sprechen viele italienisch der
mensch kann vieles sie können alles
erreichen wenn sie wollen
aber manchmal geht der weg einfach nicht
den kürzesten weg manchmal muss man
vielleicht einen umweg machen
aber wichtig ist dass sie das ziel
erreichen
das ist der richtige weg ich
interpretiere das so dass das ein titel
für die teilnahme an absolute
gesichtsverlust für ihre kollege ihre
sich schafft in den iss dome 9 ist jung
wartet das ist no go dass gott nicht
obwohl das eigentlich wieder zeit ist
ein absoluter gewinn war wie der mirror
was ich mein praktikum landschaften und
schulen aber zu das würde ihnen alles
vereinfachen aber sie sind das wasser so
und darum ist das für sie ist absolutes
versagen
und ja wir haben das schon so lübcke
data mart abschluss
das ist wie komplett versagt das
persönlichen auftreten das ist sehr gut
es gibt nichts zu bemängeln
und wir stellen ihn namen und das ist
bereits passiert
so geht es weiter einen ganzen tag lang
und meist mit erfreulichen rückmeldungen
der baumeister
hier kann man leicht erkennen
integration ist eine aufwändige sache
und es gibt leute die finden diese
ganzen bemühungen diese kosten unnötig
wer von den flüchtlingen genügend
motiviert und intelligenz sei werde es
auch so schaffen und bei den anderen sei
der aufwand angesichts der kulturellen
differenzen ohnehin vergebens
ich betrachte meine ich dass ich nicht
möglich doch einen so motiviert sie wenn
du auf die buchstadt kunden und nicht
weil ich was mache ich sterbe gleiche
könnte daheim wie der münchner zur seite
stellen aber legt dass er nirgendwo in
das loch habe keine macht nicht mehr mit
heute ist war das auto schon richtig
können eine bringen
der weg und stieß aber wenn du das nicht
rasch und der leichte bringen hast du
alles richtig dazu ist unglaublich da
das so nicht funktionieren
es ist der letzte tag des kurses und es
verspricht ein wunderbarer tag zu werden
zur schlussfeier sind betreuerinnen und
bekannte sowie vertreter der
gastrobranche geladen
ich begrüße sie an der diesjährigen
abschlussfeier vbs kuh lehrgang 2015 in
emmenbrücke
ich weiß dass sie in diesem land einen
großen spagat machen müssen mit einem
fuß sind sie in ihre heimat um mit dem
anderen sind sie hier
ich weiß nicht ob ich es genauso gut
hingekriegt hätte wie sie wenn ich an
ihrer stelle wäre dieser kurs hilft mir
auf meinem weg zur selbständigkeit und
markt mit unabhängig von der sozialhilfe
und ich auch sehr fröhlich das her geht
ist unsere freude hat uns geholfen zu
viel und ich bin sicherlich vor diese
kosten das war super für mich und ich
wollte sie verlieren heute einen schönen
tag
[Applaus]
dafür haben sie ein jahr lang gekämpft
und manchmal auch gelesen das risko
zertifikat das den absolventen des
flüchtlings großes nun zu einem neuen
leben verhelfen soll
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
vier jahre später weg ist am
vierwaldstättersee der sitz von hotel
und gastro formation der
ausbildungsorganisation der schweizer
hotel & gastro branche seit 2005
anbieterin auch des rest flüchtlings
kurses sind liebe fragen wie hoch ist
ja da bin ich richtig ich bin auf der
suche nach praktikums platz ich habe 15
motivierten flüchtling wo jetzt egal
würde dieses praktikum go
doch die rhönschafe hier hängt sich
heinz gierig ans telefon
zieht die fäden um arbeitslose
flüchtlinge in die selbständigkeit zu
führen und mit welchem erfolg das fazit
von risco kurs 2015 vier jahre danach
neun der zwölf absolventen haben in den
arbeitsmarkt gefunden
trotz der teils sehr schönes resultat
ich weiß nicht warum das die drei
personen die muppets martine sind ich
weiß aber dass sie die kompetenzen und
fähigkeiten hat und grund wieso dass sie
nicht im arbeitsmarkt denn es sind diese
natürlich sehr vielschichtig ob es meint
die moderne 12 nun dass ich das
seelische ins resultat 1 gehrig 1
schweizermacher ausprobieren
das ist bisher nicht möglich ist ich
probieren innen aber die attribut oder
die verhaltensweise mit ska damit sich
noch der einfache hand aber ich kann
nicht um eine weitere schweizer machen
schweizer wartet als mit dem sinn und
steht für mich die anderen könnte das
schweizer votum sich doch 100
integrieren da haben und sie ist eine so
21 tore
da sind wir dann einfach gut
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von bea genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
bergamotte cremiger genuss seit 1902